speaking of championship banners let's
turn to the world of sports for a moment
now nba star kyrie irving is speaking
out while remaining sidelined for
refusing the covet 19 vaccine the
brooklyn nets guard says it in three
words he tweeted god never fails because
of new york city strict vaccine mandates
irving has yet to suit up this season
for the nets and it's unclear if he'll
take the court for any road games as
well because more and more cities have
vax requirements here to react the
founder of outkick clay travis good
morning clay
got you uh
got you more than well ready here in
god's country tennessee getting ready
for georgia you can see neyland stadium
over my shoulder it's gonna be an
awesome day here in knoxville a little
chilly little chilly let's get to
knoxville in just a moment
so kyrie
saying god never fails in this in an
environment where i saw you tweeting
about this earlier this week the nba has
a rolling vaccine requirement now it
requires boosters as well clay
yeah and i think the nba is sort of uh
giving us a signal of where many
different places are going to be going
will they're encouraging everybody who
already got the vaccine to go ahead and
get the booster and for the johnson and
johnson vaccine for instance if you do
not get the booster you're no longer
considered vaccinated so for kyrie
irving you're talking about multiple
shots for everyone in the nba you're
talking about a rolling consistent not
ending covid vaccine requirement and i
think for a lot of people out there the
question is how many shots are going to
be required how long is this going to go
on and i continue to give a lot of
credit to kyrie irving because many
athletes want to talk about politics but
most of them don't actually risk
anything in the process kyrie irving is
walking away from tens of millions of
dollars will and he is standing for what
he believes in and i give him credit for
speaking out just like i gave aaron
rodgers credit for speaking out we live
in an inauthentic world hearing what
people really believe even if sometimes
you don't agree with them particularly
as it uh pertains to covet vaccine
mandates i think is an important message
that they are sending out across the
country okay let's get to where you are
neeland stadium's at your backdrop there
you're there because of the outkick bus
tour for fox sports on the big noon
kickoff show you're in knoxville where
tennessee's taking on georgia this isn't
one of the games but i just wanted to
bring this up one of the games you and i
are supposed to talk about
apparently i've just done a better job
than you clay i've got two boys and i
successfully brainwashed them both
you've got three
you're a single dad this weekend the
wife's out town and you lost one to
alabama one of your boys and you're
hoping today is when you're waiting
that's tough it's super tough for a
tennessee fan
i mean alabama doesn't lose tennessee
hasn't beaten alabama since nick saban
got to tuscaloosa so this is kind of a
fan visit weekend i need the vols to
show up give georgia a real fight here
need him to be impressed by the hundred
thousand here's the truth though will
yeah at least he's rooting more so for
the real ut as opposed to you posers
down in texas who try to claim the
initiation
down i mean what can i say with five
losses no kidding all right let's get to
your picks by the way i took tennessee
and took all those 20 points this
weekend
you did i love the points here let's get
to some of the games on fox though uh
and where you where you're seeing these
games go uh oh you against baylor i took
ou by the way and laid the five and a
half on this what do you think
yeah i think baylor's going to cover you
know oklahoma has not been consistent of
late or early in the season quarterback
drama i think what's going to happen
here baylor coming off of a tough loss
they keep it close i feel like o.u finds
a way to win by three late but five and
a half feels steep to me i'm going to be
on the bears in the big noon kickoff
game by the way those guys reggie bush
matt leinart rob stone coach stoops
they're going to be live
in about 15 minutes on big fox for
everybody who wants to get ready for the
game times all right and then at four on
big fox it's maryland versus michigan
state what do you think there
i think michigan state bounces back
maryland had a tough loss against penn
state at home last week kind of folded
late michigan state went on the road
against purdue gave up their undefeated
record but the reality is for michigan
state as long as they keep winning they
will be fine because they can still win
the big ten east if they win out still
have a lot left to play for i think they
start to get back in a good good trend
take care of the terps and roll to a
victory in east lansing back to the big
12 for the night game the oklahoma state
cowboys tcu horn frogs eight o'clock
what do you think clay oklahoma state
look we're going to find out the big 12
is still really wide open except for
texas who was eliminated a month ago
but the rest of the teams at the top of
the the big 12. they have a lot to play
for mike gundy's oklahoma state squad
wants to be rolling into bedlam with a
chance to be the number one overall seed
in the big 12 title game and obviously
knock off oklahoma i think they get
rolling a little bit tcu moving on from
gary patterson their coach a little bit
of a mess going on in that situation i
like oklahoma state the cowboys guns up
to to get things done i'm on points this
weekend this is i'm gonna call this my
points weekend i took tennessee plus 20
i'm taking purdue against ohio state i'm
taking all those points as well i like
the points you like clay's picks follow
it download you can play fox bet super
six app enter for your chance to win 25
000 this weekend all you need to do is
pick six outcomes from saturday's
college football games then watch and
see how it all plays out it's free to
play download the fox bet super six app
now